[Applause]
i don't normally do these kind of
speeches but this feels like a big
moment
i know it's not easy being banished from
mi5 to my department
but that's on you
only screw-ups get sent to
slaughterhouse
and i've got to be honest
working with you has been the lowest
point and a disappointing career
right
what are you looking for
the remnants of a once promising career
house is like prison you're not supposed
to ask what you're in for i actually
want to be useful i could not be more
bored if i tried you probably know how
many people have made it back from
slaughterhoused upstairs here at
regent's park bringing you up the speeds
like trying to explain norway to a dog
none
come check this out
hostage
he's being held here
there is something finally happening
what has it got to do with you
whatever's going on to be handled by the
real agents
[Music]
you're going to help me rock all no i'm
not
like at or not our house is part of the
snow
what do you think you're playing it
i didn't mean to kill him of course you
didn't if you meant to kill him he'd
still be alive
[Music]
you put lives in danger this is off the
box
i am directing personnel yours or
anybody else's
it's just covering our tracks
but it's the covering of the tracks it
always gets you in the end
you really care about them don't you no
i think they're a bunch of absolute
losers
but they're my losers
[Music]
you